hot breath headline is a whole
different monster
not closing the show not going last
but you [__] headline cause you
got a lot of [__] to deal with a lot of
comedy come in front of you
yeah i'm saying and a lot of [__] is on
you
see a feature ain't no pressure
appreciate no [__]
[__] don't nobody expect you to do a
goddamn thing
you're just going out there you ain't
got to sell no tickets you didn't ain't
no you ain't gonna buy
did they ain't nobody go if it's just a
lot man and then
even as uh even doing that you have to
deal with
an unknown uh unknown hiccup that's
gonna come on your ass that you're not
used to you've been doing stand up
20 years sometimes 25 years sometimes
15 and now you headline it and don't
realize
a check dropper [__] your whole setup
because you thinking you rolling then
they come drop them checks and ain't
nobody listening to your ass no more you
think you losing them nah they on they
checks
they got to drop they check then they
gotta get back to you after that you
like god
damn my shows i get that [__]
just fell out to the bottom
and then i ain't never come out of the
hole because you thought you lost them
unseen hand the vicious check drop
yeah it's legendary that's coming yeah
that's [__] coming
and me being a feature long enough
looking at hey lana's think they
bombing then i'm like hey
give your tip i know you've been doing a
stand up 30 years but let me give you
like a lightweight tip why don't you get
them to signal you
if they about to drop the checks like i
do
i just get a double light huh i'll say
well
i just asked i said when y'all dropping
the checks
and they say well we used to drop the
checks about
45 you know like 25 to 30 minutes in at
the headliner
that's how we know how much time see
people a lot of comics don't want to
learn the business enough they back in
the green room doing
whatever the [__] they doing and [__]
and not
putting a show together it's still the
most [__] you got to do once you become
a headliner
you still got more [__] you got to do so
you tell the person hey when y'all
getting ready to drop the checks
y'all do it like that give me a double
light like that
let me know all the checks bout to drop
so let me not go into no intricate [__]
or no real long story another let me
juice a bunch of quick pop [__]
because i know they about to go on
checks okay or they can't do that we'll
do this for me
drop the back first
so then i have the front then drop the
front
then i had it back i don't need the
whole room
away from me at one time i'm saying yeah
it's just [__] that you gotta put in
place for your show to be successful
i've never heard that before that's gold
and if anybody ever say they ever
thought it did a [__] lie i was
the first comic
to because i know i know other other
older comics they never thought of [__]
they was like yo that [__]
genius with that [__]
he's [__] genius with that because i
need you to know
because a comedy has to know we all in
this [__] together
so i can't have you just like with a
weight staff
i want a weight staff as low as possible
i don't want you standing up in the
middle of my [__] show
because the people behind you can't see
i shouldn't have to come in and groom a
weight stab but the comedy clubs
are not [__] focused on what comedy
should be because you're so busy trying
to just make some money
let me get the [__] sensation in here
but [__] get your [__] weight staff
together
and the shows can be a lot more
consistent have some continuity to them
so how do you share this info with them
oh they're like a meeting tell them yeah
i tell them straight up hey man i don't
want the wait staff standing straight up
okay take
orders from here because that's how it's
done at my home club at the improv
i never [__] see the wait staff at
the improv
i don't have to have no meeting with
them because they train right
they train right they they're [__]
amazing staff
i nev they like ghosts in the room i
never see them they're not blocking
consumers way
trying to give some consumers something
else even when they serving food
they come somebody come put the thing
down and they get the [__] out the way
and then you come and you put the tray
down and you serve the food low
they they get out the way they don't try
to distract anything from what's going
on on the stage because that's what's
important
just like this is important mm-hmm
you